vamos a tomarnos dos vectores no nulos
me voy a tomar el vector x me voy a
tomar el vector y en imax el vectores
que existan en rn es decir que tengan n
componentes y recuerda que lo que estoy
piden nuestros dos vectores es que no
sean cero que no sean el vector cero y
bueno yo lo que quiero construir con
estos dos vectores es la siguiente
desigualdad fíjate bien me voy a tomar
el valor absoluto de x punto y el valor
absoluto de x puntos y si te das cuenta
cuando calculamos el producto punto de
dos vectores nos da un número real por
lo tanto puedo calcular el valor
absoluto de un número real y esto va a
ser menor o igual que la longitud de x
multiplicada por la longitud de 10 y de
hecho esta igualdad se cumple es decir
quitamos la desigualdad en la siguiente
ocasión solamente cuando ocurre lo
siguiente así que vamos a escribirlo el
valor absoluto de x punto g es igual a
la longitud de x por la longitud de
james es decir que lo que vamos a buscar
es cuando se cumple esta igualdad cuando
la desigualdad entonces el valor
absoluto de x punto james es igual a la
longitud de x por la longitud de james
si pasa lo siguiente y es sí y solución
si pasa que uno de estos dos vectores es
un múltiplo escalar del otro y si
recuerdas eso significaba que uno de los
dos vectores era con lineal al otro o
dicho de otra manera que podemos ver a
uno de los vectores como c veces el otro
sin pérdida de generalidad voy a decir
que x es igual a c veces el vector 10 y
bueno a todo esto que tenemos aquí se le
conoce como la desigualdad de corsi
swartz la famosa desigualdad de coches
wards y es que justo lo que quiero en
este vídeo es probar esta desigualdad
nosotros no podemos darlo por sentado
sería muy bueno que con todas las
herramientas que hemos construido hasta
ahorita podamos demostrar esta
desigualdad y para esto me voy a tomar
una función que tal vez parezca un poco
artificial pero es una función que me va
a ser muy útil para poder demostrar la
desigualdad de corsi swartz y la función
que me voy a tomar es la siguiente
pd t es igual a la longitud
del siguiente vector voy a tomarme tevez
es el vector james y te das cuenta si
multiplico al vector por un número real
me da un vector ya esto le voy a quitar
el vector x lo cual me sigue dando un
vector y a todo esto le voy a calcular
su longitud y elevarla al cuadrado y
bueno seguramente te estás preguntando
por qué me voy a tomar esta función pero
antes de explicarte esto quiero que
recordemos lo siguiente te acuerdas de
la definición de la longitud de un
vector la longitud de un vector b la
veíamos como la raíz cuadrada de su
primera componente elevada al cuadrado
más su segunda componente elevada al
cuadrado y así cada uno de sus
componentes y ya esto definimos como la
longitud de un vector ahora lo que
quiero que veas es que la longitud de un
vector siempre es mayor o igual a 0
porque si nosotros tomamos cualquier
número y lo elevamos al cuadrado me da
mayor o igual a 0 y si tomamos puras
sumas de cosas mayores iguales a cero me
da algo mayor o igual a cero y si
sacamos la raíz cuadrada de algo mayor
igual a cero es mayor o igual a cero y
por lo tanto esta longitud que yo tengo
aquí va a ser mayor o igual a cero es
decir pdte es mayor o igual a cero
y lo segundo que quiero que recordemos
es algo que vimos hace un par de vídeos
que me va a ser muy útil para demostrar
esta desigualdad fíjate bien la longitud
de un vector al cuadrado eran lo mismo
que el vector punto el vector esto lo
vimos hace dos vídeos y bueno justo esto
es lo que voy a utilizar ahorita para
escribir la forma en la que definí pdte
es decir como esta longitud elevada al
cuadrado como un producto punto de dos
vectores es decir tevez es el vector
menos el vector x punto
tevez es el vector ye menos el vector x
estoy utilizando solamente lo que acabo
de escribir de verde a la derecha y
bueno en el vídeo pasado habíamos
demostrado algunas propiedades como
asociatividad como conmuta tividad y
como distributiva y that que voy a
utilizar justo ahorita de hecho lo
primero que voy a hacer es distribuir
este producto punto que tenemos aquí
recuerda que el producto punto es una
forma de multiplicación de vectores que
cumplía la distributiva y that por lo
tanto lo único que tengo aquí es como si
tuviera dos binomios multiplicándose
solamente que están multiplicando por el
producto punto entonces esto me va a
quedar de veces el vector
punto
a veces el vector james estoy
multiplicando el primer vector de esta
diferencia de vectores por el primer
vector de la segunda diferencia de
vectores y me queda de veces
punto tves y después no voy a tomar a
menos x el vector menos xy voy a
calcular su producto punto con tbs y que
me queda como es producto punto me va a
quedar menos x punto de veces el vector
y ahora voy a hacer lo mismo con tvc y
punto el vector menos x es decir este de
aquí y este de aquí y entonces me queda
menos de veces y menos tves punto x y
bueno por último me queda el vector
menos x que a su vez hay que tener el
producto punto con menos x y entonces
esto quiere decir que es menos 1 x lo
puedo poner así con menos 1 x punto el
vector menos 1 x date cuenta que aquí es
como si tuviéramos un menos uno es decir
como si tuviéramos una constante
multiplicando un vector 10 que al final
menos x es lo mismo que menos 1 por el
vector x
así es mucho más fácil pensarlo para no
meternos en complicaciones y bueno ya
que tengo esto esto que va a ser igual
si te das cuenta tengo t veces y tves
james aquí puedo sacar a ambas test y
multiplicar las por lo tanto me va a
quedar y punto y que multiplica a t
cuadrada recuerda que la multiplicación
por escalar y el producto punto cumplen
asociatividad y después de aquí y de
aquí voy a realizar la resta de estos
dos vectores si te das cuenta como el
producto punto y la multiplicación por
escalar a su vez son asociativas
entonces me estoy tomando la diferencia
de dos números reales iguales por lo
tanto me quedan menos dos veces el
producto punto de x punto y esto
multiplicado por t y bueno para
finalizar a quien tengo tengo menos 1
por menos 1 las constantes se van porque
menos x menos me da más uno por uno me
da uno y al final solamente me queda
ekis ekis ekis punto x todo esto
utilizando las propiedades del producto
punto y bueno vamos a ponerlo de colores
para que veas de dónde salió cada cosa
aquí los rosas sale de los rosa y los
naranjas sale de la naranja y estar aquí
es mayor o igual a 0 porque habíamos
dicho que [ __ ] es mayor o igual que 0
entonces que me ponerlo esto es mayor o
igual que 0 y por otra parte pues esto
es lo que habíamos definido como p dt
con una función de un escalar ahora
seguramente te sigues preguntando por
qué me tomé esta función y no me tomé
cualquier otra expresión o porque a
partir de esta expresión de aquí porque
a continuación lo que voy a hacer es
nombrar las cosas de una manera mucho
más sencilla para que te des cuenta de
la importancia de tener a pd te voy a
decir que a ese punto yo voy a decir que
es menos 2 veces x puntos james recuerda
que al final estos son números reales y
si también va a ser x punto x también es
un número real y ya tengo unas nuevas
definiciones a b y c entonces esto lo
puedo escribir de la siguiente manera lo
puedo escribir como arte cuadrada menos
b t esto nos va a ayudar a verlo de una
manera mucho más sencilla y a esto le
voy a sumar c y si te das cuenta a b y c
son números reales y por lo tanto
una función que depende solamente de
temp está expedito que no vais olvidar
que es mayor o igual a 0 y es mayor o
igual a 0 para cualquier t por lo tanto
no voy a tomar una t específica la cual
me va a ayudar a obtener la desigualdad
que yo tengo aquí arriba voy a calcular
quienes p debe entre 2 y voy a evaluar
esta función en el tiempo igual a b
entre 12 y lo primero que quiero que
veas es que este tiempo si está definido
es decir lo que voy a buscar es que 2a
no sea cero porque si fuera cero esto no
estaría definido pero a no es cero
porque a es el producto punto de punto y
lo más importante habíamos dicho que ya
no es un vector nulo no es el vector
cero y por lo tanto a que ese punto no
lo podemos ver como la longitud de
elevada al cuadrado no es cero porque al
menos uno de sus componentes es distinta
de cero y dos veces no es cero y por lo
tanto b entre dos así está definido y
bueno ya que me di cuenta que esto sí
está definido entonces voy a sustituir
por entre 2 ahí me va a quedar a que
multiplica a t cuadrada pero te
cuadradas de cuadrada entre 4 am ya esto
le voy a quitar bbc este pero te es b
entre 2 a entonces de que multiplica ave
entre 2 a ya esto le voy a sumar c ya
esto le voy a sumarse y esto es mayor o
igual que 0 porque recuerda que esto es
mayor o igual que 0 para cualquier tema
y bueno ya que llegamos a esto vamos a
simplificar de un poco por ejemplo aquí
tengo una idea que una dividiendo se van
y aquí tengo b por ver pues esto es be
cuadrada entonces dejemos escribirlos be
cuadrada entre 4 am - de por bv cuadrada
de cuadrada entre 2 a más se manchen y
esto es mayor o igual a 0 y fíjate bien
aquí tengo 4 hay aquí tengo 2 am
qué pasa si multiplicó a esta expresión
de aquí por 2 tanto arriba como abajo 2
entre 2 es 1 y entonces no estoy
haciendo nada pero lo que realmente hice
fue encontrar un denominador común y
entonces ahora sí puedo restar estos dos
me queda de cuadrada entre 4 a menos dos
veces de cuadrada entre cuatro a pues
esto lo puede simplificar como menos b
cuadrada entre 4
déjame escribirlo aquí abajo esto es
menos de cuadrada entre 4 am más cm esto
es mayor o igual a 0 ya continuación lo
que voy a hacer es sumar be cuadrada
entre 4 a de los dos lados de la
ecuación o dicho otra manera lo que voy
a hacer es pasar del otro lado b
cuadrada entre 4 am y nos va a quedar
que se es mayor o igual que b cuadrada
entre 4 y lo único que dice es pasar a
este que tiene signo negativo del otro
lado con signo positivo y a continuación
lo que voy a hacer es multiplicar todo
por cuatro veces a pero ojo estoy
multiplicando todo por cuatro veces
recordando quién era a ese punto y como
dijimos qué punto es siempre mayor que
cero recuerda que como ya no es un
vector nulo entonces de punto y es lo
mismo que la longitud del vector y
elevada al cuadrado lo cual es mayor que
cero
entonces yo puedo multiplicar ambos
lados de esta desigualdad por 4
y te estoy contando todo esto por una
razón específica porque si yo estoy
multiplicando todo esto por 4a y 4a es
mayor que 0 entonces esta desigualdad se
conserva
me va a quedar 4 hace mayor o igual que
b cuadrada recuerda que si a fuera
negativo lo que pasaría es que esta
desigualdad se voltearía y bueno ya que
tengo yo esto lo que voy a hacer a
continuación es sustituir quien es a b y
c para ver qué es lo que me queda
recuerda que a era el punto y entonces
me va a quedar cuatro veces amp a ese
punto
james pero oye punto y si nos acordamos
en lo que vimos en el vídeo pasado era
la longitud de ye elevada al cuadrado es
cuatro veces la longitud de james aquí
lo voy a escribir me queda la longitud
de ella que se ponía así elevada al
cuadrado del vector y elevado al
cuadrado esto es lo mismo que a porque
recuerda que a este punto
punto es lo mismo que la longitud del
elevado al cuadrado y después hay que
multiplicarlo por cm pero se es x punto
x y de igual manera recuerda que lo que
vimos en el vídeo pasado era que x punto
x es lo mismo que la longitud de x
elevada al cuadrado
entonces me va a quedar del lado
izquierdo de esta desigualdad me queda
cuatro veces a por c que es lo mismo que
cuatro veces la longitud de y elevada al
cuadrado
multitud de x elevada al cuadrado y esto
es mayor o igual que de cuadrada pero
que es esto que tenemos aquí por lo
tanto me va a quedar 2 veces x punto
james x punto y esto elevado al cuadrado
espera espera aquí es todo esto elevado
al cuadrado
todo esto es b por lo tanto tengo be
cuadrada y es que ahora sí me va a
servir bastante porque voy a simplificar
un poco todo esto me queda cuatro veces
la longitud de y elevada al cuadrado por
la longitud de x elevada al cuadrado y
esto es mayor o igual que el cuadrado de
2 que es 44 veces x punto g por x gent x
gent que multiplica a x punto o mejor lo
puedo poner como x punto y elevado al
cuadrado si déjame quitar todo esto
porque si no nos vamos a confundir en un
futuro a estos x punto de x punto pero
mejor lo voy a poner como 4 veces x
punto y elevado al cuadrado y bueno 4 y
4 se van 4 que multiplica y 4 que
multiplica el otro lado si dividido toda
esta desigualdad entre 4 se van estos 24
y me queda que la longitud de y elevada
al cuadrado por la longitud de x
cuadrado es mayor o igual que x punto
elevado al cuadrado a continuación lo
que voy a hacer es acá raíz cuadrada de
ambos lados de la ecuación y siempre
esencialmente me va a quedar que la
longitud de i por la longitud de x ya
sea que la raíz cuadrada que por cierto
se cancela con los cuadrados que tenemos
aquí porque estoy utilizando las
propiedades de los exponentes y del otro
lado me queda x punto elevado al
cuadrado raíz cuadrada pero me estoy
tomando en la raíz positiva la raíz
positiva de algo que está elevado al
cuadrado es simple y sencillamente el
valor absoluto de lo que se está
elevando al cuadrado es decir x punto g
y ojo es muy importante que te des
cuenta que me estoy tomando la raíz
positiva y por eso estoy poniendo el
valor absoluto 10 que al final date
cuenta de algo x punto que podría ser
negativo pero cuando la llevamos al
cuadrado se vuelve algo positivo y
cuando le sacamos raíz cuadrada algo
positivo me va a dar algo positivo si
tomamos la raíz cuadrada principal es
decir la raíz principal o la ra
dispositiva y por eso pongo el valor
absoluto de estos dos y adivina que ya
llegamos a lo que queríamos justo esto
era la famosa desigualdad de cosas wards
es lo que nos habíamos propuesto
demostrar y llegamos a ello después de
varios pasos pero acabamos de probar que
si se cumple la desigualdad de coches
watts bueno al menos la primera parte de
esta desigualdad porque habíamos dicho
que la igualdad se cumplía cuando los
vectores cumplían lo siguiente uno de
ellos era múltiplo escalar del otro o si
lo decimos otra manera eran vectores con
lineales así que vamos a tomarnos a x
igual hace veces y vamos a probar
solamente esa última parte a ver si se
cumple la igualdad quien sería x punto
en valor absoluto pues esto es lo mismo
que utilizando que x es igual a 0 que es
lo mismo que el valor absoluto de ese
punto james pero esto es lo mismo que el
valor absoluto de c por una propiedad
del valor absoluto que multiplica el
valor absoluto de puntos al valor
absoluto de punto bien y bueno tiene
radio punto jeff ya lo hemos visto
varias veces y el punto es ni más ni
menos que la longitud del elevado al
cuadrado por lo tanto aquí tenemos el
valor absoluto de c que multiplica a la
longitud de l
al cuadrado y bueno esto es lo mismo lo
podemos ver como el valor absoluto de s
que multiplica a la longitud de ye por
la longitud de la longitud de ella
elevada al cuadrado es lo mismo que la
longitud de ye por la longitud de james
y bueno sería muy buen ejercicio que tú
probarás que lo siguiente que voy a
hacer es cierto es muy fácil probarlo
utilizando la definición de longitud
fíjate bien si nosotros tomamos la
longitud de una constante multiplicada
por un vector esto es exactamente lo
mismo que el valor absoluto de la
constante que multiplica a la longitud
del vector es decir las constantes salen
de la longitud de un vector en valor
absoluto es decir que esto que estoy
tomando aquí es lo mismo que la longitud
de cpc
e insisto sería muy bueno que tú
probarás esta afirmación y bueno a su
vez esto multiplica a la longitud de iu
y que eres ya te diste cuenta quién
tenemos aquí
cbc si es x es el vector x por lo tanto
tengo la longitud de x que multiplica a
la longitud de james y hasta ahorita
sigues tiene una igualdad y por lo tanto
estamos comprobando que cuando
es igual hace veces el vector james es
decir x es un múltiplo escalar de james
entonces obtengo la igualdad de todos
modos espero que hayan encontrado esto
muy útil la desigualdad de corcheas
swartz la usaremos mucho cuando probemos
otros resultados en álgebra lineal y en
un vídeo futuro les voy a dar un poco
más de intuición acerca de por qué esto
tiene mucho sentido en relación con el
producto punto